Hi everyone, this lecture
will focus on opioids.
So, we can identify
opioids as full
or partial agonists,
and I will describe
the drugs that are
considered to be
either one or
the other. A full
agonist will be
morphine itself, ******.
A partial agonist
will be something
like pentazazine
or buprenorphine.
We will identify the
specific drugs and
talk about them one
by one. As a class,
understand that
the action is going
to be at the mu
receptor. So they're
considered to be mu
receptor agonists.
We're also going to
discuss the adverse
effects because, of
course, when we talk about
opioid overdose, it
becomes really critical
because the patient,
if they are not given
the antagonist, known
as naloxone they
can end up in fatal
respiratory depression.
I also talk about
pharmacokinetics and
this will apply to
various drugs that
you will be using.
So for example
methadone is a full
opioid agonist but we
use it in detox and
the reason being
is it has a long half
-life. So it's going
to prevent the
withdrawal symptoms.
You will also
recognize the signs and
symptoms of an opioid
overdose. Probably the
biggest thing to note
is that everything
will be down. Of course,
the respirations,
the heart rate,
the blood pressure,
the eyes will be
pinpoint, the pupils.
And I will talk about
naloxone a little
bit. And then I'll
also discuss what
you do with opioid
withdrawal and what
to expect with a
withdrawal situation.
So with respect
to the origin
of opioids, it
comes from poppy.
And there are a group
of drugs known as
papavirine that come
from this origin.
Not widely used, but
they do, in fact,
cause smooth muscle
relaxation and
vasodilation.
And prepararine can
be used for certain
cardiac conditions
and it can also be
utilized even though
they're not widely
used anymore because
we have drugs like
sildenafil for
erectile dysfunction.
So the idea here is
what we want from the
poppy is opium and
this plant is found in
certain areas of the
world and it blooms in
the spring and how you
extract opium is you
make cuts inside the
bulb and inside there
is a fluid that oozes
out and then it is
scraped and pressed
into kind of like a mass
and that is how the
raw opium is extracted
An opioid itself
contains 20
compounds,
believe it or not.
10% of it is morphine,
0.5% is codeine.
But you'll probably
understand that when we
talk about opioids,
there is, of course, a
chemical reaction.
And as you can see, if
we looked at the
structures of, say, ******,
morphine, and even
codeine, here to the
right, the structures
really look the same.
What's going to
change is the groups
that are at position
3 and at position 6,
where with morphine,
you're going to see
that at 3 and 6, there
is hydroxy groups.
****** you're going to
see acetyl esters and
****** is sometimes
called if you had to
say the chemical name
is diacetylmorphine
and it makes sense
because you have these
acetyl groups at the 3
and 6 position and then
when you're comparing
codeine and codeine
is considered to be
more of a weak or a
partial agonist somewhat
we use it for certain
times if we need
pain relief or as an
antitussive, you can see
that what's different
with respect to
comparing morphine to
codeine is at position
three, instead of a
hydroxy group, you
get a methoxy group. I
will never test you
on the MedChem, but
just to understand
the origins of opioids
and the poppy is always
interesting because
patients will ask
you know if i eat a
poppy seed bagel will
it test positive if i
if i have to do a drug
test and in certain
cases depending on the
patient's metabolism
how much poppy seeds
they had on that
bagel patients can can
get a a positive so
it's important if
you're knowing that you
have to have a drug
test say for a job,
most likely the
best thing is to
avoid. And if you
can't or you forget,
let the personnel
know that you did
in fact consume,
whether it be a
muffin or a bagel
with poppy seeds.
So the World
Health Organization
classifies pain probably
in three groups.
Number one is is
basically more of
the mild pain. And
that is usually
managed with
aspirin or an NSAID.
Really, aspirin is
not used anymore for
analgesia because it
does have its adverse
effects, especially
on the GI. Usually
aspirin, we use it
if the patient needs
an antiplatelet
mechanism, and you'll
study that a little
bit later. Or you can
give an NSAID,
and paracetamol is
acetaminophen. That's
Tylenol. And that's usually
what we use for
more of a mild pain.
Moderate pain, we tend
to give codeine. And
as I mentioned, codeine
is considered to
be partial, more of a
weak mu receptor agonist.
And then for the
severe pain, we have
those drugs that are
considered to be more of
the strong agonist.
And that's going to be
morphine itself,
oxycodone, and fentanyl
which we we have heard
much of it in in in
the news through the
past you know 10 years
and i will say that
when we talk about pain
i mean it is important
that these substances
don't get in the
wrong hands and we
need to be very
careful as health care
professionals whether
we're prescribing whether
we're monitoring
whether we're dispensing
medication but we also
have to understand
there's going to be
certain cases where
you have to rely on
these medications.
If you're talking about
somebody in hospice
and stage cancer, that
patient really needs
to be made as
comfortable as possible.
So we need to balance
our concern, which is
very, very great,
along with making sure
that the right patient
gets the therapeutic
effects so there's
three opioid receptors
number one is the delta
and that is responsible
for analgesia and
to some extent it's
it's involved in
anxiety and mood changes
as i highlighted in
green mu is where most
of the action of these
drugs is going to be
mostly so mu is involved
in analgesia the
euphoria the physical
dependence and then some
of the adverse effects
like the slowing down
of everything whether
it be bradycardia
whether it be constipation
respiratory depression
and and the pinpoint
pupils kappa is
also interesting because
pentazesine is going
to have a greater effect
on kappa versus mu
and you'll see it later
when I talked about
the mixed agonist
antagonist this receptor
is responsible for
analgesia sedation
hallucinations dissociation
which some people can
have in a this type of
effect if they're taking
pentazocene that is
me that means the
patient is also almost
having like I want to
say like they have that
effect that they they
almost like they're
hallucinating they're
delusional And dysphoria.
Dysphoria is important
because that implies
that that might cause
an uneasy feeling in
their mood overall.
The opioids have a G
-inhibitory receptor
mechanism. So with G
-inhibitory, another
group that shares this
mechanism is probably
the alpha-2 agonists
like clonidine.
G-stimulatory,
if you remember,
is mainly the
beta receptors.
And then the GQ,
which I have discussed
a couple of times
already in this
semester, can apply
to alpha-1 receptors,
perhaps muscarinic
histamine receptors,
and later when we
do serotonin-2A.
But G-inhibitory, and
it's going to kind
of tie in, because
this is a depression
of adenyl cyclase,
okay? Where the
drug binds, it
dissociates from the beta
and alpha dissociates
from the beta
and gamma part
of the receptor.
And you're going to
get now a decrease in
adenyl cyclase, a
decrease in cyclic AMP.
So that brings
everything down.
the heart rate,
the depressed mood,
the effects, say,
on respiration.
And with respect to
calcium, there's going
to be an inhibition of
the calcium channels.
Okay, you're blocking,
and that's going to
prevent calcium entry.
So you're going to
get a decreased
intracellular calcium. that
in essence is going
to open the potassium
channels and allow
potassium now to enter
and overall those two
effects on the calcium
and the potassium is
going to decrease the
release of neurotransmitters
and those are
the ones that are involved
in pain transmission
so it makes sense some
of the pharmacokinetics
and I'm not going
to be exact but
just to explain the
group as a whole they're
well absorbed and they're
rapidly distributed
they're going to be
highly lipophilic
and that makes sense
they're going to cross
the blood-brain barrier
cause sedation they're
going to cross the
placenta so we have
to be concerned with
pregnancy and the effects
of these drugs on the
fetus they undergo
a first pass effect and
they're glucuronidated
glucuronidation is
phase 2 metabolism.
And what's going to
be important is that
there is metabolites.
The main one for
opioids is the morphine
6-glucuronide, which
itself is even more
potent than morphine.
And that means that if
you have somebody with
a renal dysfunction,
because the next point
is that these drugs
are renally excreted,
they're going to develop
more adverse effects.
So you have to dose
this especially
carefully in somebody
that's renally impaired.
And the elderly,
again, I can't say it
enough, are going to be
more sensitive. So you
need to watch the dose
here because, again,
you're going to induce
sedation, possibility
of falls, and
then in worst case
scenario, there can be
respiratory depression.
Normiperidine is a
metabolite of meperidine,
and we'll talk
about that drug
specifically towards
the end of the lecture.
This particular
metabolite is actually
excitatory in
mechanism where it can
actually increase
the risk of seizures.
So again dosing
especially in renal
impairment is going
to be very important.
And then we can give
these medications through
spinal delivery and
I've had members of
my family who have
had surgery and in And
the hours after surgery,
a pain management
nurse usually administers
this through a
spinal route, and that
helps control the pain.
And the need to give
dosing, because the
dosing schedule can be
a problem. And this is
why we have patient
-controlled analgesia.
And this really means
that the patient
themselves, when
they feel pain,
they're going to
press a button that
they're attached to
while they're in the
hospital, and
that's going to give
them a controlled
amount of analgesic.
It has a lock feature,
so they're not
going to be able to
give themselves more.
They're not going to
have a problem with
overdose, because
the issue is, if we
wait too long and
now the patient is
in pain, severe
pain, you're going to
need a greater amount
of drugs to bring
that pain down. and
that induces tolerance
and it can induce
adverse effects.
So basically what
I'm saying is
if you can get
ahead of the pain,
it's much better for
the patient, both with
respect to tolerance
and adverse effects.
So with analgesia,
we have several
categories and sometimes
you'll see that in
certain books, they
might be in different
areas. But the way
I classify them
is the strong agonists
are the common
ones that we associate,
morphine, methadone,
******, meperidine,
and fentanyl.
The mixed agonist,
the antagonist,
is buprenorphine.
And this is one of
the drugs that is
getting a lot more
use when we talk
about dependence, if
we're trying to
manage withdrawal.
And then we have the
weak or the partial
agonists, which include
codeine and hydrocodone.
If anybody has
had a wisdom tooth
extracted, there may
have been a chance you
might have gotten
hydrocodone with, say,
acetaminophen.
They call it Tylenol
No. 3 or Tylenol No.
4, depending on the
amount of acetaminophen.
So oftentimes, they
combine this with a COX
inhibitor. with codeine
sometimes they will
combine this with say
promethazine and that
can help say if the
patient has a cough
that is related to
allergies okay but remember
this still makes them
control substances
and they have to be
dosed carefully when they
are given or when
they're prescribed so
mu receptor agonists
have certain adverse
effects number one they
are vasodilators And
I explained early on
that papavirine, which
is derived from poppies,
does cause smooth
muscle relaxation,
and that will lead to
hypotension. So again,
they may have, your
patients that use these
medications, when they
take the first doses
of, say, morphine, if
they get up too quickly,
they might get a
little dizzy, and that's
due to the lowering
of blood pressure. In
addition, with that
concept, they lower
oxygen demand and cardiac
work, and they will
lower peripheral vascular
resistance, which
has to do with
vasodilation. So they will
decrease venous return,
and that's known as
preload, and afterload,
which has to do with
the effects on the
arterial role later on.
So what I want to say
is we don't really
want to give morphine,
you know, for obviously
we're not going
to give it for
hypertension, but usually,
and this is starting
to change and
some protocols are
changing it, when
patients would present
to the ED with the
possibility of having
an MI and you're
doing the EKG and the
troponins, you have
to give certain
medications and it's
usually aspirin,
oxygen, maybe nitrates.
In the past, they
would sometimes give
something like morphine
because morphine,
putting these three
points together,
would be a good thing
if we were worried
about the patient
having an MI because
it's going to lower
oxygen demand.
And the other thing
is when patients have
an MI, sometimes they
complain that they
feel that pain of a
thousand elephants on
their chest. So that
too would be appropriate
if we wanted to
control pain. But as
I said, you'll still
see it. Some hospitals
won't use that
protocol, but just
something that you should
know going forward.
The issue is that when
you overdose on this,
the respiratory
depression comes rather
quickly. and this is
due to the fact that
opioids decrease the
sensitivity of the medulla
to that increase in
carbon dioxide so
basically it's saying
that the medulla cannot
sense the carbon
dioxide and that's where
the patient will go into
respiratory depression
so the patient can
have a respiratory
rate of like eight and
that's pretty dangerous
that's when you need
to have the antidote
and And you may even
have to ventilate if
you are really concerned
about this airway.
The other thing
to know is that if
somebody has a head
injury, it's been
observed that this
may not be a good
thing to give
because these drugs
can increase
intracranial pressure.
And that has to do
with the fact that
if you are vasodilating
in some of the
vessels in the brain,
you're going to
increase volume. And
that person already
has some edema in
the brain, so that's
going to worsen
the pressure there.
So again, going back
to the vasodilation.
The GI is very sensitive.
It doesn't matter
if it's the
first time the
patient is taking
an opioid or it's
down the line.
This is an adverse effect
that has no tolerance.
Because what happens
is when you take
these medications,
you're going to decrease
contractions of the
gut. You're going to
inhibit motility.
So anybody that you
talk to who takes
it will complain of
constipation. And that's,
again, you want to
get ahead of that.
You want to make sure
that you are encouraging
fluids, fiber.
Perhaps you give them
a stool softener.
Okay.
sometimes it's not
even enough and
you have to take
other medications
post-surgery this is
definitely a problem
because number one post
-surgery the patients
are in pain they're
getting these
medications and oftentimes
you know another
thing that prevents
constipation is movement
if you just had back
surgery it's going
to be hard for you
to move around like a
regular patient would
okay the other thing
is that when we're
talking about constriction
there are certain
sphincters that might
be constricted number
one is the sphincter
of odai which is kind
of like the place
where you get the bile
between the pancreas
and and and the
gallbladder if you
constrict there you may
increase pressure and
that can increase pain
especially if you're
a patient that has
gallbladder disease.
And with constricting
the urinary
sphincter, you're
going to increase
urinary retention.
So that can be
another discomfort
for the patient.
With respect to
the uterus, they
may prolong
labor. They're
going to decrease
contractions.
And that too is an issue
because that might affect
the baby that's about
to be born. So we
have to be very mindful
because that baby
can be born with
respiratory depression.
And then with
respect to emesis,
in the chemo trigger
zone, there's
dopamine receptors.
And I talked about
that in Parkinson's
disease where there
may be some agonism
of the dopamine
receptors and the
patient is going
to be more prone to
wanting to *****.
so in the eye there
is a parasympathetic
effect so again
rest and digest
if you were running
because you saw a bear
the first thing you
would get is probably
among other things your
eyes would be dilated
because of the shock
of seeing that bear
your sympathetics are
going up so that's
where medriasis comes
into play okay and
medriasis is is definitely
true of sympathetics
so amphetamines
******* can do that and
also the muscarinic
blockers because if
you're blocking the
muscarinic receptors you're
turning on sympathetics
here it's going
to be more of a
parasympathetic muscarinic
agonism effect that
happens with the
opioids. So the pupil
is going to be pinpoint.
And this has to do
with stimulation
of the Endinger-Wasphal
nucleus in the
oculomotor nerve 3.
One thing to note is
that looking at the
patient's eyes is such
an important diagnostic
feature. Because if
you have a patient
that's coming in to
the ED and they're in
a stupor and they're
bradycardic and they're
hypotensive and their
respiratory rate is
going down and you
look at their pupils,
you could almost always
say to yourself, did
this person take an
overdose of an opioid?
And the other thing
that's nice about
it is that you don't
get tolerance to
this effect. So that's
another benefit of
having this as a
diagnostic criteria.
So pinpoint pupils for
opioids, muscarinic
agonists, and then
medriasis, you're
thinking about increasing
sympathomimetics.
Some of the other
effects that
you might see,
number one,
histamine release.
This is not a true
allergic reaction.
The patient is
going to get
something called
a pseudo-allergy.
There's some
activation of mast
cells. So the
patient might feel
pruritus, some
vasodilation,
some wheezing.
If they become
anaphylactic, that's
going to be a
different story.
But some of this
will be what we
might expect from
the medication.
true allergy
to opioids is
really not as
common as we think
there's an increase
in prolactin
and that has to do
with the fact that in
those receptors in the
tubal and fundibular area
opioids can block
so you might get enhanced
prolactin that can
affect menstrual
cycles it can
affect fertility
there might be
inhibition of LH and FSH
release and that has to
do with the fact that
these drugs can reduce
gonadical tropin
releasing hormone and if
that happens you're going
to decrease *** hormones
so again thinking
about patients that
are taking this you
know they're abusing
they may have changes say
if you were a female
changes in menstruation
men might have changes
in ****** as well
there can be some
suppression of immunity
that can occur and
that has to do with
the fact that you will
produce more cytokines
so the risk of
infection is is higher
and the other thing
is to know is you know
and and you know
for now since we we
especially in in this
part in new york state
They change
the whole thing
with the needle sharing.
You have had
some reduction in
more infectious
disease, but
that's another
problem as well.
If patients are
sharing needles,
of course, the
risk of them
getting infections
is greater.
The other thing to
note that is important
is that oftentimes
some of these
drugs, like L
-fentanyl, sulfentanyl,
remifentanyl are
injunctive in anesthesia.
They can provide
sedation, which is
needed, and they also
provide some pain
relief. And sometimes
they use this if
we're thinking about
a pediatric patient.
Next, I want to go
through what happens in
the neonate there is
a condition known as
neonatal abstinence
syndrome and this might
happen if the mother
is is using opioids
through pregnancy the
child becomes physically
dependent and when
they're born and
hopefully again there's
no problems with the
airway okay you have
to be really critical
with that they can
experience withdrawal
and some of the the
withdrawal symptoms can
be of course irritability
there's something
called a high-pitched
cry that's that's
a very very prominent
feature baby cries but
it's it's high pitch
it's very loud they
can have diarrhea or
if we're talking about
withdrawal these babies
can have seizures.
So how we treat is
by giving something
that is mechanistically
the same. So
you could use
morphine or the long
-acting methadone. They
used to previously
use, and you'll
see it in the
readings, camphorated
tincture of opium.
But the issue with
this is that there were
errors because there
was another one that
we would, I believe it
was called paragoric
there were oftentimes
dosing errors with
that and the other
thing is that even with
the dosing you had to
be very careful you
wanted to get the
effect that you needed
but you wanted to avoid
overdosing so they
they seem now that to
say that morphine and
methadone they have
better control with
the dosing if the baby
is seizing you could
also give adjunctively
phenobarbital okay
and the other one is
is clonidine because
remember with clonidine
if we are managing
some of the autonomic
effects clonidine is
nice because it's going
to stop the release
of norepinephrine
presynaptically and
that's going to prevent
now high heart rate
and high blood
pressure. So sometimes
that can be also
put in the protocol.
So one of the
issues is tolerance.
Tolerance is going to
happen with all opioids.
That means if you start
somebody on 5 milligrams
and they're taking it
for a period of time,
there's going to
come a point. The 5
milligrams doesn't work.
You have to increase
them to 10 and then
increase from there.
And that might be
due to two things.
The classic view
was due to the fact
that when you give
opioids consistently,
you're going to
get uncoupling
and you're going
to get degradation.
And that means when
it's degraded inside
the cell, there's
not going to be now
new receptors coming
back to the surface.
So that could
be the case.
The newer hypothesis
is that with
giving opioids, there
may be an effect
on the second
messenger system.
So for example,
there may be
an effect on
adenyl cyclase.
and that may be another
reason why patients
are getting super
sensitivity and now
they're getting tolerant
to the medication.
As mentioned, tolerance
doesn't hold true
for meiosis and as
I said, meiosis is
a diagnostic criteria
and constipation.
Anytime you give
opioids, patients
will be constipated
And like I said,
the best thing
to do is try to
get ahead of it,
try to prevent it.
Again, tolerance
independence should not
limit you from providing
the patient with
the best pain relief,
especially if we're
talking about end-of
-life care. At that
point, you want to
keep the patient as
comfortable as possible.
So I would say dose
slow and increase
slowly from there, low
dose and go slow,
but make sure the
patient is kept
comfortable, especially in
those situations where
we're dealing with
patients that have a
little left to live.
Opioid withdrawal occurs
6 to 12 hours after
the last dose, and it
could last for days.
It ends about three
days later. And
this is, I want to
say, and I think I
alluded to this
when we did benzos.
Patients are not,
at this point,
looking for the
high. They're
just looking to
manage the low.
Okay, and that's
where we get now, you
know, how do we manage?
We give something
that has a long half
-life, like methadone.
How the patient
will present?
They might have
a runny nose.
They might be sweating.
they might have something
called goose flesh
or they call it pilo
******** where if
you ever looked at
your arm there's hair
almost like their hair
is standing up they
might be yawning they're
going to have anxiety
aggression and now
instead of being pinpoint
their eyes will be
dilated so this is
now coming in to the
sympathetic response.
Methadone, long half
-life, and because of
that you're keeping
your patient steady.
They're not going to get
a prolonged withdrawal.
Why do people
become addicted?
Well, opioids bind to
the nucleus accumbens
and that's going to
allow for dopamine
and release. And
dopamine is the reward.
And that's what is
really mechanistically
happening with patients
that get addicted.
Hyperalgesia happens
sometimes when
medications like this
are given for an extended
period and that's
why going to pain
management trying to
fix the problem is going
to be important not
just for the story
of reducing addiction
and overdose and
tolerance but also
for this hyperalgesia
because what's happening
is the patient is
getting an increased
sensation of pain.
Why? Because maybe you're
increasing bradykinin
and NMDA receptors
and that might be
causing more of the
patient having excitatory
reactions that might
be magnifying the pain.
So morphine is the
prototype. It's the
drug, the standard
drug of the group.
It reacts with all
opioid receptors mainly
the mu but it affects
kappa and delta it's
used for moderate to
severe pain it can help
reduce the dose of
anesthesia and it has an
anxiolytic effect
okay going back to its
effects in the brain
and the fact when your
pain is relieved you're
going to just feel
better you're not going
to be as anxious for mi
as i talked about it
produces vasodilation
it decreases is the
workload of the heart.
Hypersensitivity and
respiratory disease.
So again, I did talk
about the increase in
mast cells. I said it's
not a true allergic
reaction, but if you
have somebody who
maybe is asthmatic,
that can make things a
little bit more difficult
for that patient.
The respiratory
depression is fatal.
And as I said, with
the vasodilation
and the patient
having a head trauma,
that can lead
incidentally to an
increase in volume,
which is edema,
and that can worsen
the pressure in
the brain,
intracranial pressure.
When you give morphine
with sedatives,
and that could be
cannabinoids, it could
be with barbiturates,
it could be with
alcohol, it could be
with benzos, which
we said does not
produce respiratory
depression, unlike
the alcohol and the
barbiturates, you will
get an intense sedation
and respiratory
depression will follow.
So making sure that
the patient understands
they should not
be getting behind
the wheel if they're
taking opioids and
to avoid all the
other substances,
because now you're
getting almost like a
potentiation of these
effects. And the
worst case scenario
is that they're
going to end up in
respiratory collapse.
Codeine is interesting.
As I mentioned,
at that position,
instead of having
the hydroxy
group, it's going
to be methoxy.
Itself, it's going
to be metabolized
ultimately to
morphine. It
has partial
agonist activity.
It's combined with
non-opioids like
acetaminophen
or an NSAID like
ibuprofen to relieve
moderate pain.
It has antitussive
action.
So it's going to suppress
the coughing reflex.
but one thing to
know is that codeine
is going to undergo
a metabolism that
involves something,
a SIP enzyme,
2D6, to convert the
codeine to morphine
and that's what
naturally happens but
there are some
patients that are
going to have a
mutation in that enzyme
And what will happen
is, if you have a
mutation, there's
something called a mutation
that results in ultra
-fast metabolism.
So that will mean
that codeine gets
metabolized to morphine
very fast, and the
respiratory depression
can come very quickly.
Okay,
so this is definitely
something that
is not as common,
but if you do have
this patient that
maybe had an issue
in the past and
was tested, you
probably need to use
another medication.
miperidine has a
rapid onset but
a short duration
of action it's
metabolized as i
i told you to a
metabolite known
as normiparidine
and that can induce cns
stimulation
leading to seizures
There's a couple
of things that
are specific
to meparidine.
Number one,
it has some local
anesthetic effects, okay?
But this medication
also has anticholinergic
effects. So if
somebody overdoses
on meparidine,
it can be very
likely that instead
of them getting
meiosis, they're going
to get medriasis.
Instead of them
being bradycardic,
they're going to
be tachycardic.
That's number one.
The other thing
is that meperidine
has serotonergic effects.
This is a concept
that will become much
more clear after I do
the antidepressants,
especially the ones that
allow for
serotonin reuptake.
Two serotonergic drugs
at the same time can
cause something called
serotonin syndrome.
And this is very
dangerous. number one the
patient's autonomics
will be off they'll
have tachycardia
they'll have high blood
pressure they'll have
medriasis and they'll
have a high temperature
and the other thing
is that they'll be
myoclonic they'll have
involuntary movements
if you don't control
the the temperature
which can go up to about
104 degrees the patient
can end up dying so
you need to remove the
offending agent you
need to treat the
myoclonic episode with
something like a benzo
because they can get
a seizure ventilation
can be also something
we want to do and the
other thing is that
you want to give a
blocker of serotonin
and that is known as
ciproheptadine and that
ciproheptadine has
other effects it's an
H1 blocker, it's a
muscarinic blocker it's
a dopamine blocker
but we use it for its
serotonergic blockade
for this disorder
and then monoamine
oxidase inhibitors and
again it will become
more clear when I do
antidepressants with
you again, you're going
to have a serotonin
being elevated and
that too can create
more serotonin syndrome.
Okay, so this is what I
just explained to you.
Meperidine,
dextromethorphan, and I'll
explain that in a
couple of minutes.
Lenezolid.
Lenezolid, if you
remember from antibiotics,
was a 50S protein
synthesis inhibitor. But
it has some monoamine
oxidase inhibition.
So it itself can
increase serotonin.
The tryptans are used
for migraine headaches.
They're going to be
serotonin agonists.
So this effect will
be prominent if
you're using two
serotonergic drugs.
NMS will be
something that I talk
about in
antipsychotics Because
some of the features
of serotonin
syndrome will be
similar to NMS.
Except that NMS
happens with
antipsychotics
and it happens
with halogenated
anesthetics.
And the issue is that
with NMS, it's not
really myclonic. It's
going to be lead pipe
rigidity. The way we
manage that is going to
be with something called
dantrolene. So again,
as we get through this
group of lectures,
NMS and serotonin syndrome
will be clarified.
But understand that
miperidine does have
this potential to
raise serotonin levels.
Diphenoxalate is
an antidiarrheal.
Now this makes sense
because if we know
that these drugs
that are mu receptor
agonists are going
to stop GI motility
and cause constipation,
it would make sense
that we could use
this for diarrhea.
Diphenoxalate is
going to cross
the blood-brain
barrier and
it could cause
***** potential.
So what they give
with this low
modal is the brand
name, is atropine.
And atropine
is a muscarinic
blocker. So why
would you give that?
Well, you're giving
a small dose and
the reason being is
when you give atropine,
people are going
to become so dry
that they're not going to
look to *****
the medication.
So that's what
really you're doing.
Atropine is on board
just to make it
uncomfortable for this
drug to be abused.
Lopiramide is Imodium and
you buy it over
the counter.
It is a mu receptor
agonist. It's
a derivative of
this diphenoxalate,
But how it's formulated
is that it's not
lipophilic to cross the
blood-brain barrier.
You can buy Imodium
if you are going
to, say, Mexico, and
you're worried that
you're going to
drink some of the
water and you're
going to get diarrhea.
Not too long ago,
there was a story that
patients tried to get a
high off the paramide.
technically if
you take much
more than the recommended
it could happen
but the issue is
just think about
how constipated that
person will be so
if you ever see
this in the readings
just know that
it is possible at
really high doses
but at the amount
that is recommended
that you'll
recommend to your
patient will not
have that problem
they won't get
addicted to Imodium
so now we have fentanyl
I hear people saying
fentanyl I mean
they can say whatever
they want the
way the drug is
named is fentanyl
it's 80 to 100 times
more potent than morphine
it can be given
transdermally
or transmucosally
and that's the
mechanism is that
it's formulated
like a lozenge.
So you put it
in your mouth
and you get absorption
in that way.
Very lipophilic.
It's available as
a patch and due
to the fact that
it is potent you
can use the patch
every three days.
So oftentimes if
we're talking about
hospice cases the
patient will be given a
patch a durodisiac
patch every three
days and then if they
get breakthrough pain
then you would give
something ******
that's how it works
the lozenge as I
mentioned can induce
anesthesia in
children and it does
help with some of
the pain that might
be associated in a
surgical procedure
and of course
being so much
more potent than
morphine, it is
contraindicated
in pregnancy.
And I think to
note that with
fentanyl that is
obtained illegally,
the issue is not
just this drug. It's
often laced with
other compounds.
And that's what
sometimes makes it so
complicated when the
patient presents in the ED.
Because it's not
just this drug,
but it may be
something else. And
that becomes an
issue in managing.
So that's where the
problem really comes
into play with the
******* substance.
Livorphanol is the L
-isomer of morphine.
Not so much used
today for moderate
to severe pain.
But the D-isomer is
something that
we're familiar with.
It's called
dextromethorphan or DM.
This is what
you buy over the
counter when you
have a cold and you
have the cough,
the dry cough.
It's an antitussive.
Again, not addictive
at normal doses.
But there's been some
cases where patients
will try to drink
this, a whole bottle to
try to achieve a high.
And that's why in some
cases you might see
some of these formulas
being behind the
counter in the pharmacy.
The other thing about
dextromethorphan
and the reason why
it causes serotonin
syndrome is that it
does have a reuptake
inhibition of serotonin
and norepinephrine.
And it's also
got NMDA receptor
antagonism for glutamate.
So again, that's why
we have serotonin
syndrome. and that's
another reason
why patients might
be abusing this.
But if you're taking
it as recommended,
usually it's 10
mL every 8 hours.
Patients should not
become addicted.
Methadone is
like morphine.
It's a strong agonist.
but its duration
is 15 to 40 hours.
So this is why
this drug can be
used to treat
****** addiction.
Itself, it has an NMDA
receptor blockade as well
and it's used to treat
moderate to severe
pain. So here's the
thing, even though
these patients will
use it for detox,
if they overdose
here, they're going
to be in respiratory
depression.
So that's one thing
that we have to
understand, because no
matter what, it's still
a strong agonist of
the mu receptors.
So ****** is a
Schedule 1. Now, again,
I'm not going to do
schedules, because
you'll understand
that at some point
before you practice
and start prescribing.
Schedule 1 is really
no recommended
use. This is where
it's illicit. You'll
be arrested if
you have it in
possession, and ******
is in that group.
It could be injected,
it can be snorted,
it can be adulterated,
which means that
it can be combined
with other things.
Chronic injection
can lead to collapse
of vessels, and
sometimes you can
see that if If you
are, say, working
in the emergency
department, you can
see what they call
the track marks.
It's highly
lipophilic. It's going
to cross the blood
-brain barrier
very quickly
because it has that
diacetyl group
attached to 3 and 6.
If you take it
in pregnancy,
unfortunately the
newborn will be
addicted to
******. They'll go
through withdrawal
when they're born.
even though that
the needle
sharing in some
states have been improved
the needle sharing
is going to
increase the
incidence of HIV and
hepatitis so that's
important to know
and then years
ago there's
OxyContin it's
still available
but they did change
the formulation
years ago patients would
try to get prescribed
Oxycontin. And
what they used
to do is they
used to break it.
And the powder that they
crushed, they
would snort it.
Over time, the drug
company, you know,
started to work on
new coatings. And
now the coating on it
is really impossible.
You probably could
never break it.
And that had to do
with the fact that that
patients were doing
this some patients you
know not everyone of
course we're doing this
to get the high okay
again oxycontin is
considered to be schedule
two so schedule two means
that it can be prescribed
but its liability
of addiction is still
very high So again,
this comes under the
whole umbrella that
these drugs can be
addictive in many patients.
You're going to
see tramadol,
and tramadol is
considered to
be a weak mu
-receptor agonist.
And it's also a
reuptake inhibitor
of both norepinephrine
and serotonin.
You can precipitate
withdrawal if you
are not taking
this appropriately.
It also is going to
be metabolized to
morphine through CYP2D6,
just like codeine.
And those that
are ultra-fast
metabolizers can end
up in respiratory
depression. So you
have to be very
careful with this
medication as well.
It can be used for
neuropathic pain.
And neuropathic pain
can happen, say,
after somebody has an
episode of shingles
or maybe they have
diabetic neuropathy.
It can be combined with
acetaminophen or NSAIDs.
I think it was called
Ultraset, or it
is called Ultraset
as a brand name.
Tependidol is newer.
The reuptake is more
on norepinephrine than
serotonin. But one
thing to know is that
either one of these,
even though Tependidol
is less because it has
less serotonin reuptake,
it still can cause
serotonin syndrome.
So again, this
concept is going to
come up over and
over with serotonin
syndrome and what to
look out for, what
drugs to avoid,
and how to manage.
Now we have some
other medications.
Number one, we have
methyl naltrexone.
This is if the
patient is taking
opioids, say
they're using it
because they have
metastatic cancer,
and now diet,
exercise, and
laxatives are
not working, this
will treat the
constipation.
Interesting
med, it does not
cross the blood
-brain barrier
because it has an
ammonium cation.
So what does
that mean to you?
It's too polar to
cross the blood-brain
barrier, so it stays
in the periphery and
it binds the receptors
in the GI tract.
Alveomopan is going
to treat something
called postoperative
ileus, where the patient
maybe had surgery and
now they're trying
to get the GI tract
to get going again.
And the patient,
you know, in the
interim has some
constipation.
Again, it's going
to block the mu
receptors in the GI
tract specifically.
If you give this
medication in a patient
that has had opioids
within seven days,
you can induce
withdrawal.
The other thing
is this medication
carries a warning.
It's going
to be given in
the hospital.
You should not use it
more than seven days.
and another thing
is that it has
been associated
with a higher
risk of myocardial
infarctions.
So again, you have to
really do a
risk assessment.
If the patient
has had MIs in the
past and has
atherosclerosis, maybe
this is not what
you want to do.
Now we have the
mixed agonist
antagonist. We
have pentazesine,
butorphanol,
and nalphalene.
They have decreased
addiction potential
because they're going
to bind the kappa
receptors more than
the mu receptors.
So you're going to
have less physical
dependence and less
respiratory depression.
Except that with
pentazesine, which has
the most agonism
at the kappa, as I
talked about earlier,
you can't get patients
getting delusions
and hallucinations.
The other thing to note,
and this is important,
these drugs
can precipitate
withdrawal in
those patients that
are taking
morphine or ******.
And the reason being
is they're partial
agonists. So in
itself, they have some
opioid block because
a partial means that
it has some agonism
and some antagonism.
So if you gave
this pentazesine to
somebody that was
taking morphine,
it was addicted,
what you would end
up doing is they're
not going to
get pain relief. If
anything, they're
going to have
withdrawal symptoms.
It makes sense because
these are
partial agonists.
another partial agonist
is buprenorphine
and not only is it
partial agonist in nature
when it binds to
the mu receptor it's
going to dissociate
slowly from the receptor
at higher doses
it's going to be a
blocker because it
has kappa blockade
this medication is a
substrate for CYP3A4
So anything that inhibits
will raise this
drug's level.
It's given in
a few forms.
Sublingual, so
that means it's
a tablet under
the tongue.
Transdermal as a
patch or parenteral.
The adverse
effects are similar
to both morphine
and potassacine.
And it treats
opioid dependence.
So what makes this
a little bit nicer
than methadone is that,
remember, methadone
is still a full agonist.
If you overdosed
on methadone, you
could end up in
respiratory depression.
This is a partial,
and plus it's binding
to a receptor,
and it's moving off
the receptor slowly.
The other thing is
that it can be combined
with naloxone as a
drug named suboxone.
And if that's the
case, should the
patient, by chance,
take ******,
you have an opioid
blocker on board.
So this one is
starting to be more
of the preferred
drug that we use for
detox due to its
pharmacokinetics.
So naloxone, important.
It's given intravenously.
It's given intranasally.
Okay.
It's fast onset within
one to three minutes.
But here's the thing.
It has a rapid offset.
So this is the reason
why. If you have
a patient, and we
know that this is
sold over the counter
in a nose form,
the patient
overdoses, you
hand him the nose spray,
I would not wait
there and just
let things go.
He should also
be on his way
to the hospital.
Because the issue
is, the rapid offset
means that he could
go back into toxicity.
So making sure the
patient gets to
the hospital is
number one. In the
hospital, you have
to keep giving
this until the
opioid is cleared.
So if it takes, I
don't know, two hours,
the patient is going
to be there for
several hours. Until
the opioid is cleared
from the body, you
have to make sure
that you're monitoring
the patient.
Because naloxone is
really fast to offset.
The other thing
to know is that
in those neonates
that are born
and have respiratory
depression,
because the mother
was a ****** user,
you would give naloxone
to those babies as well.
I talked about naltrexone
earlier. I said
that when we have
alcohol use disorder,
that giving oral
naltrexone is a good
thing because number
one, it's long-acting
and it's going to
decrease the dopamine
in the nucleus
accumbens. So it's
going to stop the
reward and it's going
to stop the craving
for the alcohol.
The other thing
that you're going to
see, and you know,
right now it's all about
GLP-1 agonists and
that makes sense.
But there is
a formulation.
I believe it's Contrive.
Or Contrive, yeah.
That is the brand name.
This is a weight
loss drug that's
also approved and it has
bupropion and it
has naltrexone.
Now, bupropion is
an antidepressant,
is a reuptake inhibitor
of norepinephrine
and dopamine.
It's also a drug
that you'll see later
on that blocks
nicotinic receptors or
you could use it for
smoking cessation.
um but with naltrexone
this is this is
really you know
important and with
propion and the idea
of weight loss um
there is something that
is in the hypothalamus
and it's called
propiomelicortin
and this is responsible
for decreasing appetite.
So bupropion,
when you give
it, is going to
increase POMC.
And that makes
sense. So that would
make sense that by
giving bupropion,
you're going to
feel less hungry.
Excellent.
But one thing to
know is that when
this happens,
there's going to
be a release of
beta-endorphins.
And beta-endorphins will
shut off this mechanism.
So the idea here is
endorphins come from,
their origin
is opioids, mu
receptor, all
of that. If you
give something
like naltrexone,
that's going to stop
this negative feedback
where B-endorphin
shuts this thing down.
okay so this is
stimulated with bupropion
this will be
released be endorphin
and then naltrexone
comes here and blocks
it so that more of
this can be released
and the patient has
less of an appetite
and that will result
in weight loss
opioid *****
again when we're
talking about how the
patient presents
everything will be down
heart rate is down
respirations are
down blood pressure
is down they are
in a stupor they
might be unconscious
endomiosis
give naloxone if
you gave it at home
in a nasal form, get
them to the hospital.
Once they're in
the hospital, they
get it intravenously
until the opioid
is cleared and you
also ventilate.
With withdrawal,
you would expect,
again, some of the
sympathetics that I
talked about, maybe some
sweating, some
yawning, some tremors.
And then you would
also want to give
something that's
long-acting, like
methadone, or the
partial agonist, the drug
that dissociates
slowly from the mu
receptor, that's
called buprenorphine.
So again, I don't
want to get into
the scheduling,
but understand that
something like
****** is Schedule 1.
Schedule 2 is going to
be a lot of the drugs
that we talked about,
oxycodone, meparidine,
methadone. As you
go down, it's still
considered to be a
controlled substance, but
they have less of an
addiction liability.
The benzos are
in Schedule 4.
Cannabis, as of
the moment, even
though it's legalized
in most states,
is still Schedule
1. And that's where
the discrepancy comes
because federally
it is still considered
to be illicit
while in most
states it is legal.
That can change.
But just understand
that when you
talk about scheduling,
you have to be
very careful in
how you prescribe.
And just as I
mentioned, you have
to be mindful of
state laws because
between states,
things can change.
Benzos are very
strictly monitored
in New York State,
but if you went to
another state,
like maybe Montana,
it may not be as
carefully monitored.
And I guess it has
to do with the amount
of people that are
in places in the
country. More people
are in New York City
than they would be,
say, in Montana.
So, in practice,
make sure you're
very familiar
with state laws.
Seuss Trigene came
out last year this was
the first non-opioid
analgesic it works in
the periphery to block
sodium channels so in
many ways this kind of
looks like maybe the
anticonvulsants but
it's working periphery
and that's going to
have an effect on pain
Muscle pain, maybe.
Right now, it's
used for moderate
to severe acute
pain. They don't
recommend it more
than 14 days.
And some of the
adverse effects
may be some
itching at the
beginning, some
nausea and vomiting.
And it might, since it's
working maybe
in the muscle,
it may cause increased
maybe contraction
due to this mechanism,
perhaps. and
patients may experience
an increase in creatine
kinase and increasing
creatine kinase
happens when you get
like muscle spasms
okay creatine kinase
might also be like
something we check
when the patient has
myalgia associated
with statin use and we
use statins for
cholesterol Those are
associated with muscle
pain and weakness.
And one of the things
that we check is the
creatine kinase,
because if it's high and
the patient maybe is
experiencing dark urine,
that can be due to
the muscle breakdown.
So again, this was
just approved in 2025.
There's still a
lot of data that we
need to collect
now that it's
marketed on an
outpatient. So we'll see
what happens with
this medication.
So I will be, of course,
having a review, a
recorded review. So I
would say that this will
be important for you
to go through the
classes of opioids, how
they work, mainly at
the mu receptor, and
kind of distinguish
between the full, the
partial, and the mixed
agonist antagonist.
And then, of course,
to recognize an
overdose and how
you manage and how
you will give that
naloxone until
the opioid is cleared
from the body.
So until then, thank
you for your attention.
Please direct any
questions to me, and
I will see you soon.
Be well. Thank you.